welcome to this episode of trash taste
uh that's a strange topic that we didn't
mean to get on but uh welcome i'm your
host connor with the boys cheering on
although as we've established the host
means nothing now as someone on the
trash taste reddit uh pointed out i
explained to them i was like on my live
stream i was like listen you don't
understand you get power when you're on
the solo seat you get space you do yeah
i i don't know how to explain it you
just get like a feeling that you you're
like i mean i'm in control i'm in the
conversation like like every time when i
hosted before and there was a guest
store and i'm just like well that's
that's my hosting privilege it's gone
because i gotta take care of the guests
i'm on babysitter mode now now you're in
the beta seat i hate that suit the most
i feel like i'm furthest away from
everything i'm like hi guys
i crushed yellow crust
a part of me just feels like i like
these two seats i like that scene i like
this sheet too
that's literally never given a [ __ ]
i'm like we're still sitting at the same
time
something about it just you know feels
different you know it's it's like
it's like getting like the front seat in
the car you know you you are you are the
alpha male if you're five years old yes
you are
oh okay i'm sorry
every time we go on a road trip joey's
the one that shotguns the front seat
every [ __ ] time i swear to god
yeah exactly i'm doing i'm doing it for
the driver all right there's more
responsibility for me you can chill in
the back see the front seat's only good
if the driver is also really confident
because the driver is confident that
he's not going to bother you yeah with
the driver but if the driver is not
confident then he's going to bug you
okay you look at the map actually can
you change the song
we can stop there's like no but if the
driver is chatting
but even if it's a confident driver
right you're going to be the one guy
who's like you know someone in the back
is going to be like hey can you turn up
the ac it's like oh fine [ __ ] all
right that's awesome this is why i feel
sorry for any short person who is on a
group road trip right because here's the
thing
no matter what no matter what we think
no matter what we think is the best c in
the car we can all unanimously agree
that the worst c is the middle c in the
back right yeah and who always gets that
it's the short person because they take
up the least space because i can always
be like look guys i'm a bit tall can i
can i can i get at least can i at least
get one of the side seats and everyone's
like all right guys i understand i'm
just like i love i love how the people
throw in that argument as if
like the the ones on the one that isn't
the middle seat has more legroom or
something like we all have the same
amount of leg room so it's like
you're like worrying about invading two
people's leg room yeah as opposed to
just guarding europe oh is that the
logic i think so but also it doesn't
really have to do that much with heights
yeah it's about which yeah yeah yeah
like because you could be like eric
cartman right eric cartman is like
everyone in south park yeah like like
how where is he going to sit yeah you
know i mean yeah for me it's always like
it's it's whoever has like the smallest
stature
which a lot of the times happens to be
the shortest person oh that's true but
there are some like short thick people
out there in the wall so i was like
i'm sure they are but i'm just saying
every time every time because i'm always
the person that forgets like shock on
the front seat so i'm just like if i
can't get the front seat there's i'm
there's no way in hell i'm getting the
middle seat you'll catch
oh you want you want me to take the
middle c oh okay well uh oh i guess
these long legs have no space to sit hey
oh let me just let me just uh i'm just
man
as much but yeah let me just like man
spread as much as possible so you can
regret this decision of putting me in
the middle seat god's polite enough that
way if you're like god get in the middle
seat can't be like all right yeah yeah
but it depends on the length of the
journey if it's a short journey i'm like
i'll take the middle i don't really yeah
even even in a short trip i don't want
the middle like an hour in the middle i
can do an hour and a minute that was
short
yeah
i'd say like four hours where it gets
like long four hours you can throw me in
the trunk man
i'll have a better time in there
yeah i don't know like it's it's the
middle c especially it's not just like
the least comfortable it's just the one
that induces the most motion sickness
for me as well because i don't get
motion sick because the problem with the
middle seat is that it's always got like
the shittiest seatbelt right like like
that's a waste yeah it's it's the waste
only one so it feels like the the top
half just like has less
um what's the word i'm looking for like
supports it has less support right
you're you're you're nice and small
makes you motion sick
it kind of like
a lot of things make me worse one of
those people who literally needs to be
like [ __ ] straight jacketed into the
seat to be like no motion sickness
because because the other thing as well
is a lot of the times the middle c
doesn't have a head rest as well so a
lot of part of part of the thing that
helps me with motion sickness is having
something to rest my head on it sounds
like a tall person problem it it very
much is a tall person
problem either i get motion sickness or
i just have like massive whiplash from
just like trying to lie
trying to lie like this for like two
hours well then after saying all of that
can you really fault me for shotgun in
the front seat
clearly so i can avoid [ __ ] sitting
like this for the entire trip right now
that's why uh that's why that's why
short people deserve to be in the middle
you don't need a head rest you're short
enough as it is i i need a head rest
okay
he wants them all to sit in the middle
seat for the rest of time this is the
birth of heightism
is that a thing is that a thing
maybe probably
if you're on tinder you can't
you can't call them short
that's that's that's gonna end up being
derogatory at one point of our lives
because everything ends up being
derogatory also there's no clear
definition for when somebody becomes
sure exactly right vertically challenged
that's all we have to start using from
now on